[Music]
and welcome back to another really cool
episode of the careful boys where today
we are so fortunate to have Giani in the
building
W I got to come here more dude I get mad
applauses here dude I'm like what you
it's like it's like 3:00 a.m. on Sunday
I'm like what are you guys doing and
we're like
Johnny it is great if you need support
just you know a little bit of collapse
just us okay cool we'll be around yeah
we'll be around serious question for you
okay dude you guys are [__] he's like
when's what was the worst day of your
life I'm like [__] and then look at this
butthole no more call I've done 8,000
call backs they're not going to make
sense they're going to make sense okay
what have you been meaning to do that
you have not done yet and why haven't
you done it oh what the [__] what
happened you meaning to wait
huh what have you been meaning to do but
you haven't done it yet and then why
haven't you haven't done it yet yes yes
perfect wow honestly I feel like the
second I feel like I need to do
something I do it oh that's dope yeah so
there's nothing you feel like I've been
meaning to do this it's just if I need
to do it boom just do it not like get
married or have children I hate both of
those things not even like butt sex done
it yeah both
ways no but yeah the second I feel like
I have not done something I need to do I
do it like I even like skydiving I don't
I have no need to I kind of get the
sense of that retirement account like
immediately boom call up [__] I have
it [__] what's those bro his Roth is
filled up dude okay he he does 10
actually you know what I want to
purchase a home but I feel like I'm not
I'm not ready yet because I still live
half the year in New York I'm still
working on the show so like I can't
there's no point yeah there's no point
but like that's like the thing that like
I want to do next is like purchase a
home we got one yeah we got Applause
again but why why do you want to buy
home um get one Vegas it's a good price
I I want to live in I love La although I
do love Vegas and that that I do agree
with that there's a Noble in Vegas too
there's a noble okay fine dude I get
in I'm like can I get a permanent room
at the nooo um yeah I just it's why do I
want to do that is that what the
question was why yeah why do he asked
you why do you want to do it I I just
feel like um like living in apartments
or renting homes like it doesn't feel
like your home like like when you
purchase something you're like oh [__]
like this is my [__] like I you can now
grow corn or something right corn I
would love to grow corn can you grow
corn in La yeah yeah grow really good
weather for corn yeah well that's what
I'm saying so it's like I I feel like
like I want to start like you know then
you can build out [__] and this and that
like when you're in an apartment or
you're renting a home you can't really
change stuff around so I feel like you
feel like you're in one place you know
it's locked down yeah that's good we'll
clap again yeah [__] yeah dude no I
won't I'm going to save mine okay that's
fair save M for later
holding what about you Nicholas that's a
hard one I'm trying to think right now
I'm trying to think too holy [__] you go
first yeah you go first I can go for
Nick if you guys want me to no dude stop
I could go for Nick if you guys want me
to try try see if it's on point yeah
what would Nick say what would Nick say
what have
you I really want to learn the Twister
uh I feel like it's a really good
submission
The Twist he's
right word oh
God he wants the fight has bua what do
you what do you do what I haven't done
but you need to do but I haven't done
that's a hard one what have you been
meaning to do but haven't go see my
[__]
grandma oh D yeah bro dude call her bro
I do call her but she can't hear when I
call her that's for hearing like for
real like as of She's Like H like
legally clinically death typ probably as
of this what like week year past couple
months well how far is she she's in San
Francisco that's far I thought he was
going to say Singapore a 45 minute
flight but like it is but it's not why
why haven't you done it cuz I'm a
[__] bad I feel like I'm a bad family
member dude like I just this is how you
make yourself better yeah no for real
like I I just talked to my uncle that I
haven't talked to in like two three yeah
but it's not your fault if they're
annoying well it's not even that they're
not like they're annoying like you know
it's like other Fam Family [__] that
like you kind of get wrapped into and
it's like weirdness it's kind of weird
and we had a conversation and it was
good to talk to him and you know what I
do when they do that to me what I say
shut up I like them independently and
you shut the [__] up and then they go
okay okay okay but now everyone's in a
place where everyone's a little more
chill more relaxed everyone's like older
so we kind of understand these like
weird Dynamics between older adults you
know it's like [__] like that but you
know I talked to my uncle and I was
really good and after I hung up the
phone I was like damn bro like I need to
see these [__] more like cuz
i't seen my cousins and they were like
10 years old and they're like 22 23 I
haven't seen them in a really long time
uh my grandma's obviously getting that
age where you know it's probably getting
close then go see you go see that okay
put it in your calendar right now have
to probably do November go to kayak.com
there's a plane ticket to San Francisco
it only probably cost you less than 100
bucks round trip you're going to go over
there you're going to say ha
poo this dude flies back and forth this
dude flies back and forth from Hawaii
every N9 days for the show you can't go
to San Francisco I'm like
dude but yeah but you know what it is
the mental gymnastics of it if I'm being
honest what's the mental gymnastics of
it my mental gymnastics is like I got to
do this I got to do this and it's true
cuz I do have a lot of [__] that I have
to do while I'm here you know and like
you know work as [__] but I need need to
take the L for that week or not an L but
take the time you feel if like you don't
get that chance anymore yeah I know
that's why something happened and then
you're just just got that's L that's a
capital L and I don't want to do I don't
want to live my life like that with like
family and [__] cuz I think that's a
weird thing that I have with my family
is like I kind of like don't like them I
kind ofid flight hey book your flight my
flight I'm going to book for nov fly
[__] you fly hey not that this is not
supportive anymore this is a little
scary now okay B the [__] flight
dude take us later you better and San
Francisco has amazing Chinese food it's
only 90 bucks and you could go to
Fisherman's W he found it right now I
told you less than 100 he goes is it pre
is it United nonstop
90 all my points
Delta I'm more of American Airlines kind
of guy but yeah Americans that's the
mental gymnastics it's like listen what
are we talking here if it's not Frontier
I don't want it dude um but yeah no that
is something that weighs heavy on my on
the front of my brain you can do it
that's that you recognize it though yeah
I'm a piece of [__] dude I'm a bat I
think no don't say that don't say that
I'm not I'm not a piece of
[__] we can get you out tonight at 8:25
let's do it n dude hey let's relax bro
hey 8:25 you go over there at 9:00 she's
probably sleeping yeah so I got to wait
in the morning she'll probably wake up
at 4:00 in the morning what if you do do
a same day flight flying in the morning
kick it with them for that's actually a
that's a really good idea and fly back
at night yeah I could do that cuz it's
not that bad it's not it's a 45 minute I
can fly out of Burbank dude see I love
flying out of Burbank amazing that's the
only airport I feel you know what's odd
though it takes about 6 hours to drive
to San Francisco three to drive the Las
Vegas but they both take 45 minutes to
fly get it well well one is a lot is
probably a lot of traffic from San
Francisco right and then the other Vegas
is very just like the desert but even
San Francisco is like it's like an hour
10 you know what I mean it's a it's a
little longer a little bit longer it's
barely longer but that's kind of a big
deal 20 minutes in Flight like versus
you know cuz you're going a couple
hundred miles an hour that makes sense I
just don't understand why it's the same
time for all
the can't wait for you to book your
flight with I think it would be
wonderful no I'm going to I'm going to
thank you for putting me on on uh you
know get you brought that up through
your own desire think we just manifested
it's conversations I have with Tiff too
and she's like stop being a [__] and
I'm like all right don't talk to me like
that that's a thing and that becomes
another argument so instead of stop
being a [__] it's more like hey start
being a good grandson yeah yeah you're
right a good son overall I think dude
how many [__] birthday cards she give
you with $5 in them over the year oh
yeah she'll give me calls you know I
mean even though she can't hear you my
uncle will my uncle will a then [__]
don't go see her this is my last Grandma
I only got one left bro you know I only
got one on the mom's side or the dad's
side my Dad's side oh that's nice that's
my 9 dude that's what we call it that's
cool poo dude
po what does that mean yeah what is poo
I just made it up so the PO the popo is
uh your mom's side N9 is your Dad's side
oh so I was kind of right yeah you're
close but they're both
grandmas it's confusing you can try what
in a is that a language chinesee I
didn't want to step on anyone's toes it
just was curious is that a language I
don't want to assume anything you know
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
like this
Lumi so that is the Lumi starter pack M
there's all kinds you got wipes wipes
you got the stick you got the stick you
got the whole body the cream version we
got the cream version that's lavender
and we got the acid body wash
a acidified body wash it's not acid wash
watch out don't don't think about that
yeah but the whole thing is pH balance
designed by OBG so you can go like this
and go like this right after and
everything smells good and it smells so
good but don't go like this no I think
it's for the outside not the
inside and because it's designed by obgy
you know it's meant for your whole body
pH balance no parabens no aluminum and
it is perfect for people with sensitive
skin and if you smell like [__] and I
never use deodorant but I use this
because it doesn't smell like a [__] no
and it doesn't have metals to destroy
your body with metals and chemicals 72
hour Odor Control that's a long time but
don't think that you can't take a shower
but if you need to be in the forest for
72 hours you could be Super Fresh some
people smell like [__] after 4 hours
that's true
but this is 72 hours that's a long time
so as a special offer for listeners
that's you guys new customers get $5 off
a lum starter pack with code OTR at
lumid deodorant.com that equates to 40%
off your Lumi starter pack when you
visit Lumi deodorant.com and use code
OTR thank you Lumi for making this
holiday season smell a whole much better
72 hours better I thought she was just
in law
enforcement
how' you guys know she was
undercover yeah all this time what about
you JoJo Jo Jojo I have no goals okay
what about you cleen I have no
goals that's an answer I didn't know I
could I would have said that D I have
like all the goals I I want to make a
million by the time I'm 33 that's a good
idea I want to buy a house too I'm going
to take your goals I want do so two
years you make a million dollar no dude
you can't take our goals dude back the
[__] up dude [__] your dude keep your
own goals like get to like
34.4% Chinese by 33 wait are you
actually 33% Chinese yeah damn I got
[__] dude got so [__] got nothing dude
did you want to be 33% you're 99%
Italian dude this is how [__] white I
am dude I got Sushi last night from
Whole Foods dude I'm a [__] you're like
better the
chef where's the chef is some guy named
Ricky he's like Ricky Garcia bro he bows
to him oh thank you deep BS de below
he's like why are your shoes off in the
whole boot put your shoes on I'm like my
bad dude my
bad sick knife
Ricky
stupid that's pretty cool goals to have
a million by 34 what else I want to Trav
I'll do that too take your goal what
have you been meaning to do but haven't
done yet and why haven't you done yet oh
yeah but why haven't you okay
well you know what that's a complex
question $0 [__] the house [__] all this
[__] um I want to learn how to be a
pilot like a helicopter pilot how come
not a plane pilot I mean maybe that's
too but either or I'll take why haven't
you why haven't you done that is
expensive all of our goals seem like
doable but you need a budget you need
money you need budget time and yeah
budget and time both both of which I
don't NE helicopter pilot license is
better though why I have a friend that
has it and the biggest the biggest is
you don't need a Runway yeah so your
backyard he literally does it from his
backyard you can I'll get one then and I
feel like there's there's more locations
you can yeah you can fly anywhere and
land anywhere which is [__] sick
helicopter's pretty handy but you you
need to let people know you're flying no
no no you just land on their
house a lot of them like just like
people I ride motorcycles ride dirty a
lot of them just ride dirty well cuz how
they got to air traffic control
sometimes well they going to pull you
over that's the
thing
[__] there's there's like there's
like air tower map you got to come down
sometime if you're flying between those
you don't really need to really yeah you
don't need to also my my grandpa uh was
a pilot in World War II he was a armor
pilot so I think that would just kind of
yeah that's what I was going to ask you
guys should talk about it what side was
he on let's not do
that maybe he met my grandpa was he on
the was he on the 77 side or the 33 side
yeah you know something I haven't asked
him you don't have confirmation yeah
yeah I think just by looking at him you
could figure out what side he was on
definitely the 77 side a damn it you
think a grandparents will we be friends
probably met in the air say Hi
Five that would be so funny I know huh
so no goals huh uh with all the goals no
goals you have all goals with no goals
this doesn't make any sense to me I I
don't I I yeah I'm kind of like Johnny
in a way where it's like oh that's a
good idea and then you just start
working toward it right right so the
only reason it's kind of boring right so
let me try to make it entertaining um I
think the New Passion that I have right
now is um buying businesses so I'm in a
deal right now but these things take
like 6 months to a year to fin and it's
hella boring why can't you make it
faster Joe that's a good question huh
really good question I don't
know make it
FAS hey I don't sound like that you took
it too far that's what you sound like GI
didn't do it like that yeah yeah now I
just want to take everything I learned
from startups so patreon everything I
learned from you know digital marketing
everything and then I just want to um
put it into businesses that I feel like
are amazing and do are just like yo I'm
trying to retire but my kids don't want
my business and I'm like okay that's
cool I'll take it you know yeah that's
kind of where I'm at right now with my
buddy my childhood friend yep nice why
haven't I done it yet I am doing it and
I'm just waiting I'm just like come on
what kind of business is you buying um I
can't really say right now but it's just
a company that's been around since 1950
and it's a leader in the market
Coca-Cola yes dude oh
that's I don't know dude that just came
to me Coke Zero for free you could have
all the COK you want
bro who's left Mr
anth what have I not done yet that I
want to do I also want to buy a house
but we'll get there um I would love and
why haven't you too though that's the
thing I'm a barber yeah dude well I cuz
I don't want to make enough money here I
feel like most of our things is just I
don't have enough money yeah just money
Richard yeah yeah that part you already
know the mortgage rates are ridiculous
right now okay other than that uh I
haven't broken 90 yet in a golf score
cuz I'm not that good yet so I just need
to train more that's a non- monetizable
goal it's still expensive golf's kind of
expensive it's going against your house
what was that the golf is going against
your house it's taking money away from
your and I need a friend to tell me that
just like we got to tell him to book his
flight I need somebody to rationalize
with me dude you should walk here in the
morning cuz the gas prices they're going
against you getting a house I just saw
650 is [__] crazy it is that's crazy
why is nobody talking about this so I
just around everywhere electric vehicle
we should go there yeah um $4 in Vegas
keep going what' you say okay got it
yeah it's cheaper in Hawaii get they
have to ship gas over there and it's
cheaper to get it than here in
California you technically ship gas over
here I don't
know how come here's my question and I
hope this isn't racist How come every
time you guys don't really understand
the question you go into an Asian accent
is that the pattern I feel say that that
was an Asian accent was it not I did I
don't know GI to it just sounds like
voices to
me it doesn't sound like an accent to me
I just hear voices that's all what do
you hear GI I just heard something a
little different
but manuck I'm just going to open SN he
he didn't bring that I brought this he
didn't bring that from his
house he's using her
props uh I've been meaning to
um create life you know what I mean
w I know I know leaving it in huh you're
married I am married nice dude so you've
been doing unprotected sex I've been
meaning to I haven't done it yet you
[__] Heen I'm still answering the
prompt here have not you're going to
start responsible I would like to I
would like to try this year yes is she
on the same page is she is why this year
why why not next year or the why not
last year is it cuz you're aging yeah
I'm aging yeah that's one way to put it
you
know um yeah no it just it just feels
like this is a time like we're just more
ready both mentally both like
financially uh even for her just like
career-wise like because she's been
focusing on like you know solidifying
her career over the last couple years uh
same with me just like understanding
where I'm at and the evolution of like
how things have been going um my health
getting my health into the right place I
said I like kids but do you want to take
care of mine how many kids you got Joe
if I have one do I want to take care of
your kid short answer no long answer no
you
have if I had though I just need someone
I can pawn it off to I think that's what
your wife might be helpful with or your
mom or her parents or or those
businesses you're
buying maybe I'll get a day K put it in
the
contract yeah he's like kill two birds
with one stone baby and throw your kids
in can buy Coca-Cola but can't get a
baby you have a kid right that kid is
[__] cute i' I've seen him on social
media I'm like that's a [__] hot I
mean that's a cute
kid cute kid dude you call
them I feel safe
now dude I'll bring him
around n he is he's a really cute
kid when you put overalls on him he look
like a Chinese dentist to Menace with
his [__] up
teeth what accent was that that was
[Laughter]
[Music]
English